pas de bousculade pas la moindre côut
seule une poignée de militants s'est
rassemblée hier au qg de campagne
pendant que leur candidat françois
fillon est attaqué par son propre parti
sur les chaînes nationales ici ses
partisans refusent de lui rejeté la
faute
je pense qu'il a eu du mal à se départir
des affaires qu'il ya eu 2 voilà de
passer le nez hors de l'eau si je puis
dire
il ya eu un sursaut un petit peu
d'orgueil de valeur que ça c'est certain
je pense que c'était un bon candidat on
y est triste parce qu'on a quand même on
a bien travaillé on était contents on a
fait tout ce qu'on a pu
françois fillon n'ira pas au second tour
il s'est tout de suite engagé à soutenir
emmanuel macro face à marine le pen et
appelle ses électeurs à faire comme lui
une annonce qui est mal passée chez
certains monsieur fillon se trouve
effectivement pris un petit peu entre la
peste et le choléra
mais je pense que beaucoup de gens vont
réfléchir quand même on ne peut pas on
ne peut pas laisser les rênes d'un
gouvernement un homme aussi jeune c'est
pas possible
pendant ce temps à mâcon le
dépouillement se termine les résultats
locaux donnent emmanuel macron et jean
luc mélenchon en tête dans ce fief de la
droite françois fillon n'est que
troisième du scrutin
une double peine pour le maire les
républicains j'ai une pensée ce soir
pour mon ami françois fillon j'ai une
pensée je mesure la déception parce que
je suis aussi déçu pour tous les
militants et sympathisants qui se sont
employés pendant toute cette campagne
des primaires d'abord puis après de la
campagne présidentielle qui ont beaucoup
dépensé qui sont beaucoup dépensés qui
sont battus pour convaincre et dans une
campagne un peu difficile de ce soir
sont un peu déçus et les électeurs de
françois fillon hante encore deux
semaines pour choisir à qui sera lié
leur tract ne voudrait plus d'ici
[Applaudissements]